hey I'm tan and I'm obsessed with other
peoples obsessions my name is lenio and
I am obsessed with cats I only had four
cats when I moved out here currently we
have about 700 adults and about 300
kittens I I say I'm eccentric slash
masochistic okay that's yours it sounds
better than crazy next we're gonna go
look for all right I don't know how
people dismembered human beings be so
close I like cats a shitload I love cats
you know my first word was cat all the
VHS family videos that had me looking
through books you're doing at pictures
of them it's embarrassing but then
there's one day I count Lord at cat
house on the king´s she has over 1,000
feral felines yeah
one thousand and is said to have given
and literally given her five bedroom
house over to her cats and now lives in
a trailer instead so naturally I wanted
to meet her spend 24 hours in her shoes
doing anything and everything that she
would naturally all right you ready to
do this I'm ready okay let's go she's
gonna call Beth who is líneas assistant
hi Beth it's time from BuzzFeed here
we've just bought into your copper and
the 995 to go I'm about to meet the
ultimate cat lady do you know how that
feels
I don't know how do you know it's a
privilege it's an honor and it's a
little bit terrifying
we do lockup at four o'clock cityscapes
lakh but she'll probably give you the
code so in case you want to go out and
get dinner or anything yes and you're
from Australia Daphne yeah Sofia when I
first got there I was instantly
gobsmacked at how big her property was
she had peacocks for [ __ ] sake I could
feel a little bit of apprehension from
her at first and you know I get it it's
easy to take the piss count ladies are
the butt of so many generic gags but it
wasn't long before she started telling
me a little more about what it takes to
be obsessed with cats and then she took
me on a little tour of the grounds I
moved out of my 4,200 square foot five
bedroom home and gave it to the cats and
I live in a trailer I was normal for
many years of my life and then I got a
divorce and then I went to some
traumatic situations and I kept saying
to myself you're supposed to be doing
something with your life and I never
really knew what it was and then after I
started rescue I realized that you
bought a 4,200 square foot five bedroom
home on six acres and you're single with
no kids
then this started like Oh somebody
planned this for me so I worked for
three years out of it and how did you
know when it was time to leave your
house only that they would jump from the
top under my soul
and then they would run across my face
biting and I have scholars I was a
little bit confused about some parts of
the conversation oh there's that the
black and white one is the one that was
exiled
his name is Sultan but I changed it to
Isis
his name is Afghanistan he was about
Middle Eastern
she knows I'm Arab right but otherwise
most of it was cool so she's invested in
her retirement in building separate I
see use and various sections throughout
a property for the sick old young and
in-betweens and in the winter they have
heaters and in the summer they have
misters and ceiling fans and a water
cooler
basically they they live better than me
yeah we're getting into feral territory
these are the antisocial the wild watch
me and I won't touch you I belong I like
the play which have you always loved
cats yes or no one would let me have one
look at me now fixture gimmick I think I
went a little overboard mm-hmm so what
are the numbers for you people wondering
how the [ __ ] she feeds 1000 plus cats so
every week Linnea purchases 1,300 pounds
of dry food 1,000 cans of wet food 600
pounds of litter 60 rolls of paper
towels land gallons and laundry
detergent six gallons of dishwashing
detergent and 600 trash bags
look at so what you think so we're
halfway through the 24 hours it feels
like we're in a post-apocalyptic world
that has been overrun by guts all humans
have been defeated and we now have a cat
Lord
he's the bus
is it a pillar into the cat it's both I
realized that night that putting a
couple of hundred cats in one house is
like if the walking dead and
Kardashian's made a love child we grab
some dinner and then fed them suffer
much I mean it was a time something
happen
went to bed suddenly it was a [ __ ]
a.m. there's so many cats at the door so
in the morning we'll have you mixed the
food and and while you're there you're
gonna have like fifty hungry cats just
yelling and screaming and you know and
then after that we'll take the platters
all the way down to the river and feed
the kennels and then we can probably do
the medications and the feeding at the
kittens they even do poop walk witches
walk the property with a little thing
like it Disneyland or the rake tomorrow
done so I made about 20 trays of food
and gained some upper body strength you
haven't taken any
of course
seven days a week we're gonna wash the
dishes from the record then I cleaned I
mean what I'm skip
it's kind of like panning for gold look
at that gold my god [ __ ] up a bit I
put the kitty litter in the wrong bucket
well I just have to rinse the feces of
my mom and so what's what now blue block
so we take the poop off that's the
litter box I thought that I had shoveled
[ __ ] already but apparently not Benjy
that's number one out of the Rosalyn
yes another pooed next we're gonna do
that boxes yeah a big box out front
these are our outdoor litter boxes there
are probably 20 or more and then we had
a couple of dramas we've just to have
somebody come in with a surgery someone
just brought in a cat from the protocol
public that they want to get spayed or
neutered and we have
you fill out the form with an intake and
then we can go to the vet and then
brailleback
then came the kittens hundreds all right
so with explained now we're going to be
kittens all right mate say goodbye to
your balls
I tell them that'll make a good man
this time there's probably 200 in June
there were probably 300 is you know
kittens and then the the other building
next door would also have been full with
another hundred that it were sick
take that bombs ease eyes most of them
we're doing pretty well and you know
some someone having a rough time nobody
wants to give them a chance it is
heartbreaking that so basically when the
kitties come in we have to put them
under quarantine immediately at least
for two to three weeks just to make sure
everything's in order and when we do
that we just give them probiotic about
this is that you can just buy from
Amazon and if we encounter any issues
with them then we have to reach out to
our best check out their little eyes
make sure everything's okay with them
somebody's gonna give them 0.5 feet all
right that's all done how many more to
go we have the whole world to do toys
work her way that way
so usually takes us all morning this
little little run here when you holding
your heart breaks and you just want the
best for you I can understand how many
procession will go from there and how
you would just want them all to have an
equal chance at life you obsessed I
think you kind of have to be huh did you
want coffee okay
did you enjoy the litter box DeeDee sigh
mom you did a great job and then she
suggested we get some air we could take
a walk on Beacon Australia and we're
taking your gun with us when you're out
there there's nobody but you hopefully
and that if a coyote comes and I've had
them challenge us and I've had them
trying to take one of the dogs that
anything that makes noise is a good
thing two Rottweilers in a 38 special
you know you're safe amazing that's
yours
I don't normally shoot unless I'm a
coyote in tax but since you wanted to
see what it's like to live out in the
country look out shoot at that sign
I'm gonna pull the camera back does it
find out how to shoot a gun
what's the hammer it
next we're gonna go look for pencils all
right what a morning I haven't even had
breakfast yet when I was talking about
how she found a dead coyote a month or
so ago in a field and one of the skull
so after our bonding sesh we headed over
and found it I mean this has absolutely
nothing to do cats and you know I'm
vegetarian but it was still a time so
why not include in this video yeah I
don't know how people dismembered human
being here at your turf okay you're the
bag lady and you're taking this home
right no so we've been up for six hours
shoveled a lot of [ __ ] fed hundreds of
mouths cut off for coyotes head shot
some guns probably should just have a
glass of water and and that's right
about now and then suddenly we were
having our last words my obsession with
cats I've kept in control I have never
taken in more cats than I can afford so
I feel that because I can take care of
them and they expanded them all and that
I the facility is good and the cats are
healthy that it's not a bad obsession I
gave up my retirement my home and my
life for cats would you have it any
other way I have no regrets the people
that don't agree with what I do they
think I've gone overboard they think
that there's something wrong with me
what do you think I think maybe they're
right
I am obsessed about it but my obsession
is to the point where this is the most
important part of my life and I don't
mind I mean at the end of the day this
obsession has done a lot of good we have
rescued 30,000 plus cats and eight
thousand plus dogs so the county hasn't
taken in cats even to kill them for over
five years
there's 200,000 on the streets so we get
them out that's we're like the Costco
the wholesaler they were newborns when
they came
all covered in metal I want to fix it
and I can't fix it and I get angry and I
just puts me right back into the guy
I've got to save yeah and I kind of get
it it's so easy to look at someone and
and call their lifestyle unhealthy but
she's got something that gives a meaning
to me it is just a way of life I get up
in the morning and I'm happy that's all
that counts
I guess the majority of the time we see
obsessions as negative things things
that can overwhelm us restrict us but
then they are seized
obsession is something that's really
causing even
which is really cool for birds it's just
life as normal as it is for us to be
able